[Musique]
entretiens politiques avec raphaël se
dit bonjour vous êtes préfet délégué
pour l'égalité des choses dans les
yvelines alors c'est une fonction que
peut-être les gens ne connaissent pas
forcément bien on va essayer d'expliquer
voilà qu'elle est quel est votre rôle
quelle est votre fonction
c'est une fonction qui a été créée en
2005 est ce ça oui c'est ça c'est une
fonction qui a été créée en 2005 mais
pas à l'époque dans le département des
yvelines en ile-de-france il y avait que
la seine saint denis le val d'oise et
l'essonne qui avait un préfet délégué
pour l'égalité des chances et en 2020
très récemment le gouvernement a décidé
de créer un préfet délégué pour
l'égalité des chances dans tous les
départements d'île de france je vous ai
et c'est vous qui avez été doué serre en
2020 donc exactement à peine un peu plus
d'un an maintenant et donc au palais
c'est vrai que ça oui ça a été créé dans
un certain nombre de départements et le
rôle aux faux départ s'était parfois
d'apaiser détention non dans certains
quartiers c'est pas juste d' apaiser des
tensions au début en tout cas c'est vrai
que le contexte dans lequel il a été
créé ont été créés des préfet délégué
pour l'égalité des chances et est
marquée par les émeutes de banlieues qui
avait eu lieu au cours de l'année 2005
toutefois le rôle du préfet délégué pour
l'égalité des chances c'est pas juste
d'apaiser les tensions 1 et on est
d'abord ici pour incarner une promesse
républicaine que la promesse d'égalité
des chances aux promesses difficiles à
tenir mais pour laquelle les préfet
délégué pour l'égalité des chances se
bat au quotidien
d'abord dans les territoires en
politique de la ville mais aussi pour
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes qui sont
dans le besoin dans la difficulté ou
dans la souffrance et qui ont besoin du
soutien de l'état pour parvenir à une
pleine émancipation
l'ajustement var up on appelait les
textes et rendre plus effectif le pacte
républicain à promouvoir la cohésion
sociale lutter contre les les
discriminations favoriser l'intégration
des populations immigrées en tenant
compte de la spécificité de chaque
territoire alors est ce qu'il ya
ça veut dire quoi à la fois intégré et
tenir compte des spécificités
alors ça veut dire que le rôle du préfet
délégué pour l'égalité des chances se
déploie d'abord dans les territoires en
politique de la ville qui sont les
territoires les plus en difficulté de
notre de notre pays sont les territoires
qui concentre le plus de pauvreté et
c'est vrai qu'une grande partie de mes
missions concernent ces territoires à
peu près la moitié de mes missions
concernent ces territoires avec deux
grands axes la rénovation urbaine est
pour moi très important parce qu'on ne
crée pas de les conditions d'égalité des
chances il n'y a pas de la mixité
sociale dans chaque quartier on ne crée
pas de mixité sociale s'il n'y a pas un
urbanisme qui permet cette mixité
sociale avec une mixité de logements etc
et puis des actions de soutien à la
politique de la ville où ça aux jeunes
notamment dans ces quartiers qui ont
besoin du soutien de l'action publique
pour parvenir à s'émanciper mais ce
n'est pas la seule fonction que l'on que
l'on a parce que là
les difficultés à atteindre le plein
respect du pacte républicain ne se borne
pas aux quartiers en politique de la
ville donc on a aussi tout une action
pour favoriser l'emploi notamment
l'emploi des jeunes pour l'accès à
l'hébergement c'est une problématique
importante sur le département des
yvelines pour l'accès au logement et
pour la lutte contre les discriminations
vous l'avez mentionné on pourra y
revenir c'est aussi une problématique
très importante sur ce sur ce territoire
je reviens à ce que vous disiez
justement sur la mixité sociale c'est au
fond
des responsabilités mais il ya peut-être
eu parfois une politique de ghettos vous
faut qu'ils aient fait ou des gains de
fins politiques ou en tout cas des
ghettos qui sont constitués voilà il ya
est ce que c'est une politique je crois
pas il n'y a jamais eu de vraie voilà
y'a jamais une volonté consciente d'un
dirigeant politique quel qu'il soit de
dire voilà on va constituer un ghetto ce
sera mieux il ya une tendance assez
naturel
d
[Musique]
des habitats sociaux à ceux à se
regrouper ou des politiques à construire
de l'habitat social sur un même
territoire et puis
d'autres communes à se protéger de
l'habitat social et ça peut constituer
au bout d'un moment des questions on n'y
prend pas garde des ghettos dans un
certain nombre de territoires
l'histoire en français a été marqué par
cette réalité qu'on a construit de
grands ensembles sociaux dans les années
60 pour lutter contre les bidonvilles
pour et la constitution de ces grands
ensembles a coïncidé avec la
désindustrialisation et donc ses grands
ensembles de sont progressivement
appauvri vidés de leur classe moyenne et
ont progressivement constitué des
ghettos et tout le travail que nous
mettons en place c'est justement de
lutter contre ce regroupement de la
pauvreté des difficultés d'intégration
dans des mêmes territoires c'est un
travail qui est très difficile qui est
longue et fastidieuse et souvent
caricaturé mais qui portent des fruits
moi je défends et à preuve à l'appui que
la politique de la ville la politique de
rénovation urbaine ça marche ça produit
des résultats et ça permet à la france
de faire vivre son pacte républicain
même si c'est des résultats qui sont
modestes et même si la politique est
difficile c'est vrai que vous pourrez
avoir parlé avec des responsables locaux
par exemple des vignes disent que
maintenant il ya une certaine fierté des
habitants invités un quartier ce qui
n'était peut-être pas le cas il ya
quelques années on attend entre les
vignes à mantes-la-jolie omneari le
quartier de politique de la ville c'est
quoi c'est surtout chanteloup
on a des quartiers politique de la ville
à poissy le quartier le plus important
en taille c'est mantes-la-jolie si le
val-fourré plus vingt mille habitants
c'est plus grande c'est plus grand de
françois et c'est un quartier qui est
très très emblématique de la politique
de la ville on a les mureaux qui est un
quartier aussi connu on attrape qui fait
souvent la une des médias pour de
mauvaises raisons alors que c'est un
quartier dans lequel il se passe des
choses formidables aussi
voilà on a un certain nombre de
quartiers dans notre territoire d'autres
qui sont moins connus la verrière mon
repas on en a on a des quartiers en
politique de la ville on a en tout plus
d'une vingtaine de quartiers en
politique de la ville sur 16 communes
dans le département des yvelines donc
c'est que c'est quand même une réalité
tangible
à cette phrase
tenir compte des spécificités de chaque
territoire
jusqu'où on peut aller dans des
politiques peut-être de discrimination
positive en respectant les principes
républicains
la discrimination positive alors la
discrimination positive est un terme qui
étaient directement et est directement
tiré du droit américain et c'est vrai
qu'on serait on serait souvent mal à
l'aise pour le pour leur prendre un
autre compte en revanche vous savez
donner plus à ceux qui ont le moins
c'est une idée qui est vieille comme la
république c'est pas une idée qui est
une idée de discrimination positive ce
qui est interdit en france c'est de
faire des discriminations en fonction de
la couleur de peau et par exemple mais
donner plus à un quartier qui a le moins
faire une opération de rénovation
urbaine ou des financements publics vont
intervenir pour aider par exemple mantes
la jolie a transformé son centre ville
ça c'est une politique est éminemment
républicaine et qui ne heurte aucun
principe donner plus
par exemple parce qu'on va aider
l'emploi dans les quartiers en politique
de la ville par une politique d'emploi
france est une politique qui
républicaine voilà donc je crois que
risqué ce qui est interdit et
heureusement interdit c'est de segmenter
la population en fonction de l'origine
ethnique cultuelle culturelle des
habitants ça c'est antirépublicain
donner plus à ceux qui ont le moins
c'est une politique qui est vieille
comme la république qui est pleinement
légitime et pleinement attendu par les
français
l'idée de pacte aurait plus qu'à squats
c'est de le président de la république
macron dans ce discours des mureaux
disait il faudra rendre la république
plus attirante
ça veut dire quoi
du président
en pratique
moi je crois que c'est important dans
les quartiers parce que je pense que son
discours des mureaux s'adressait
notamment à une population dans les
quartiers en politique de la ville qui
peut se sentir à certains moments
abandonnés par l'état ou laissés pour
compte
donner à havas a ses quartiers le
sentiment est pas que le sentiment des
exemples concrets d'une réussite et
d'une pleine appartenance à la réal à la
république et à sa promesse républicaine
mais enfin je veux dire si c'est que des
mots ça ne donnera pas
c'est quoi le sentiment d'appartenir il
ya une gaine double dimension je pense
effectivement comme vous le mentionnez
il ya un sentiment d'appartenir à un
tout qui nous dépasse un sentiment de
fierté de fierté nationale et de
participer à un ensemble plus grand que
nous qui forment une communauté de
valeurs et de destin qui est la
république ça c'est la première chose et
puis il ya autre chose dans la promesse
républicaine qui est une promesse
d'émancipation
c'est le fait que quelle que soit votre
lieu de naissance quelles que soient vos
l'origine de vos parents quelle que soit
leur parcours antérieur vous ayez accès
aux mêmes chances de réussite et c'est
ça qui est au coeur je trouve de la
promesse républicaine
c'est compliqué à faire vivre parce que
la réalité de la vie amène à une
reproduction sociale donc ça nécessite
un combat permanent disons le en france
on a des progrès à faire je pense que
c'est à ça que le président de la
république faisait allusion c'est à dire
qu'on sait que pour une enfant qui naît
dans une famille pauvre il faudra un
certain nombre de générations nous dit
si génération pourra arriver au haut
niveau moyen alors j'ai des calculs
on peut qu'on peut discuter mais donne
une
grandeur delà de la difficulté de la
tâche qui est devant nous et en même
temps si on le voit au quotidien si pour
un jeune des quartiers si pour un jeune
de qui vit dans un milieu rural pauvre
si pour un jeu il a le sentiment qu'il
est enfermé dans sa réalité sociale et
que rien ne pourra l'extraire de sa
réalité sociale et qu'il est condamné à
ne pas réussir alors on a beaucoup de
désespoir dans notre société et on peut
avoir même une crise politique assez
profonde donc c'est vraiment un travail
de tous les instants et c'est un travail
qui est très important de remettre
par des politiques actives par des
politiques d'éducation par des
politiques d'emploi par des politiques
aussi de soutien aux associations par
les politiques urbaines un peu de un peu
d'égalité des chances dans nos
territoires parler de la production
sociale c'est vrai on entend beaucoup
dire l'ascenseur social est en panne
d'ascenseur républicain même oui est ce
que c'est votre sentiment pour ceux qui
justement il ya des c'est peut-être de
vision un peu un peu faussée des
réunions et des souffrances qu'il ya
vraiment une crise avec justement ce
dont je parlais tout à l'heure la
désindustrialisation la perte des
emplois non qualifiés
l'arrivée dans un pays de chômage de
masse on a eu une vraie difficulté avec
notre ascenseur social je veux un
exemple très qui singularise la france
et qui nous met toujours en difficulté c
le chômage des jeunes quand vous avez d
une grande partie de la population jeune
qui est au chômage que ce sont les moins
qualifiés voilà 25% 20%
que ce sont les mieux payés voilà donc
vous privez en fait toute une série de
notre jeunesse d'un accès rapide au
marché du travail et donc d'une
possibilité de rattraper les inégalités
de naissance qui ont fait qu'elles ont
qu'ils ont cette jeunesse - moins réussi
à l'école par exemple
toutefois les choses s'améliorent et
enfin je veux pas être
de deux éléments deux éléments d'espoir
là dessus on voit dans les quartiers de
plus en plus toute une jeunesse qui
réussit qui réussit par l'école par
exemple les conventions sciences po ont
fait énormément de bien dans nos
quartiers twitter tous les dispositifs
d'égalité des chances font énormément de
bien dans les quartiers puis on voit des
jeunes qui réussissent indépendamment
même de ces dispositifs
qui s'insèrent professionnellement qui
réussissent à monter des start up et qui
sont l'élite de la france de demain et
ça fait d'abord plaisir à voir et ça
marche et puis on a un certain nombre de
révolutions silencieuses qui se passe
dans le pays qui permettent d'améliorer
l'accès des jeunes à l'emploi je pense
par exemple à l'apprentissage on a une
vraie explosion l'apprentissage malgré
le contexte sanitaire on ne s'est pas
démentie donc on a des facteurs d'espoir
mais c'est l'ascenseur social c'est
aussi une politique active qui est
difficile et qui est-ce qui consiste à
se battre contre la tendance naturelle
des inégalités à se reproduire on entend
souvent aussi nous dire qu'il ya
certains quartiers qui ne sont plus dans
la république qui obéissent à d'autres
lois
c'est c'est vrai ça use est un fantasme
il ya une très large part de fantasme
c'est à dire que ceux qui disent ça
généralement ne vivent pas dans ces
quartiers ne sont pas au contact de ces
quartiers donc à une très large part de
fantasme qui s'alimentent c'est vrai il
faut le dire sur le fait que dans un
certain nombre de quartiers on a assisté
à une forme de repli communautaire
qui a beaucoup de causes qui a on peut y
voir d'abord la cause de ce dont on
discute est tout à leur fait que là où
la république recule là où la promesse
républicaine n'est pas tenu le risque de
se replier sur sa communauté l'isr
d'origine fantasmes et peut être grand
on a aussi ce repli communautaire à des
causes qui ne viennent de l'extérieur on
a des pays qui ont une politique active
de promotion notamment d'un islam
rigoriste qui
qui voit là contre lesquels qui
constitue une influence étrangère contre
lesquels il faut lutter
ça existe c'est un des thèmes de
l'élection mais ce n'est pas tout tout
n'est pas fantasmer maintenant de là à
dire comme on l'entend parfois que ces
quartiers sont perdues qu'il n'y a rien
à faire que tout et non c'est pas pour
ça par contre c'est absolument faux il y
avait bien des manifestations de repli
communautaire qui sont préoccupantes
contre lesquels il faut lutter on a fait
voter une loi récemment qui je crois
donne beaucoup d'outils aux préfets pour
lutter efficacement contre les
manifestations de repli communautaire là
où elles sont inquiétantes où elles sont
séparatistes et en même temps si j'ose
dire on a dans ces quartiers
il comprit attrape aux mureaux à
mantes-la-jolie on a dans ces quartiers
d'énormément de jeunes qui réussissent
qui font vivre les valeurs de la
république et qui apporte un démenti à
ceux qui disent que ces quartiers sont
perdus
pas manichéen quoi c'est pas blanc ou
noir c'est un combat c'est difficile
mais c'est un combat moi mon sentiment
si je devais dire est ce que ce combat
bout les quartiers et perdre et gagner
mon sentiment c'est qu'on va gagner un
peu d'optimisme complètement
complètement il ya le système dislab et
l'islamisme est un des thèmes importants
de la campagne présidentielle il ya un
autre thème notre obole beaucoup ses
suites d'immigration ne veut pas de vous
demander de de juger les les
propositions des candidats des uns et
des autres c'est l'immigration c'est pas
votre rôle mais vous êtes aussi un
spécialiste de l'immigration vous avez
occupé des fonctions importantes là
dessus mais est ce que dans le
territoire notamment des yvelines il ya
des concentrations d'immigration qui
rendent justement difficile
du questions sur la difficulté de
l'intégration sur l'emploi alors dans le
territoire des yvelines
l'essentiel de l'immigration mais comme
beaucoup pendant beaucoup de territoire
français ce que les français perçoivent
comme étant une immigration et beaucoup
l'immigration passé en fait c'est à dire
que les phénomènes migratoires qui sont
constatés par les français dans les
quartiers en politique de la ville s'est
beaucoup des gens qui sont arrivés
pendant les trente glorieuses et c'est
beaucoup les enfants de ces personnes
donc on parle pas vraiment en vérité
d'immigration alors c'est beaucoup dans
les yvelines l'immigration marocaine
algérienne sénégalaises notamment qui
est important dans sa tombe de
territoire mais qui date pour une très
large part pour une part majoritaire et
qui sont en vérité alors plutôt des
enfants d'immigrés que des immigrés en
tant que tel enfin il ya les immigrés
mais il ya la deuxième génération des
plantes qui est qui est de nationalité
française
et qui
se sent fondamentalement française dans
son for intérieur qui se sont
fondamentalement française même si elle
sait qu'elle a une origine étrangère
même si parfois les discriminations la
envoie aussi à son origine étrangère
mais donc c'est difficile de lier c'est
ça que je veux dire la politique
d'immigration actuelle avec la réalité
migratoire ressenti parce que c'est une
réalité migratoires qui produit qui
provient très largement du passé c'est
ce qui rend très souvent les débats sur
l'immigration un peu difficile parce
qu'en fait on mélange tout on mélange
la lutte contre les discriminations les
flux migratoires la présence étrangère
en france la présence de d'une
population immigrée et de ses enfants en
france bref beaucoup de choses il ya des
réfugiés voilà on amalgame beaucoup de
choses ce qui fait que c'est souvent le
discours sur l'immigration est souvent
confus mais voilà si vous m'interrogez
si vous m'interrogez sur la population
immigrée dans les yvelines je dirais que
c'est très souvent une population qui
est arrivé maintenant il ya longtemps
et qui a des enfants souvent dans les
quartiers en politique de la ville mais
pas exclusivement qui se sentent
pleinement français mais je reviens
juste d'un mot à cette question de
mobilisation parce qu'elle était assez
central dans le débat qu'on entend
aujourd'hui il beaucoup beaucoup de
mesures depuis 30 ans ou 40 ans un mât
beaucoup de lois beaucoup de
rires aussi une politique européenne qui
étaient importantes en matière
d'immigration et on al'impression il
faut que les choses ne changent pas
tellement est ce que c est une bonne
année quand on entend en tout cas les
des candidats maintenant il faut prendre
des mesures alors qu'on a l'impression
que des blessés plusieurs ont été prises
depuis longtemps non il ya des choses
qui ont changé sur la politique
migratoire au cours des mille faux
prendre le temps long c'est vrai que si
vous regardez
année après année il ya déjà des
invariants mais à des choses qui ont
changé je crois qu'il ya la france se
caractérise par deux ou trois éléments
importants
d'abord on a une immigration
professionnelle qui est très réduite en
france et ça c'est un choix qui a été
fait en 74 donc ces vieux et sur lequel
on est assez peu revenu parce qu'on
avait une immigration professionnelle
passe est très importante l'un deuxième
choix qui a été fait qui a ses
structures en maintenant qu'un choix qui
a une lui une quinzaine d'années qui est
de faire vivre les mobilités étudiantes
on arrive m'accueille beaucoup c'est
quasiment aujourd'hui notre premier flux
migratoires en france 1 90 me les types
de séjours
d'étudiants étrangers c'est plutôt un
élément du rayonnement c'est pas une
immigration qui reste très
majoritairement après le refus des
règles et ils reviennent dans leur pays
d'origine et ça permet de développer la
francophonie et puis on a beaucoup en
france une immigration familiale qui est
lié au fait qu'on a une population
antérieurement immigrés qui regroupe
bien voilà c'est le regroupement
familial c'est le fait d'épouser un
étranger lorsqu'on est français bref
c'était un certain nombre de phénomènes
migratoires contre lesquels les la
capacité du pouvoir politique à l'utc
essentiellement lutter contre la fraude
lutter contre les abus mais pour le
reste on peut pas interdire un français
d'épouser un étranger et de vivre avec
lui en france donc les outils sont
nécessairement limité mais voilà donc on
a des invariants de la politique
migratoire française
que les lois tente de faire vivre et
adapté aux réalités des flux migratoires
contemporain mais c'est pas enfin y'a
rien il ya là de très jeunes
qui souhaitent chalumeau et après il ya
des immigrés sur soi les papiers pour
être là ce soir ils sont dans une
situation d voilà après la politique
migratoire et une politique relève des
principes sont relativement dont les
principes sont simples dans la mise en
oeuvre est complexe parce qu'on est à 10
ans devrait complexe mais très
rapidement sur une pâte humaine
des 110 hommes et des femmes cd en soins
individuels des enfants des donc c'est
forcément une matière qui est complexe
dans sa mise en oeuvre qui est dans
lequel l'immixtion du droit est très
très forte en touche très vite à la
liberté d'aller et de venir ou aux
droits humains donc c'est normal que ce
soit une politique complexe après il ya
une partie de la complexité de la
politique et une partie de la
prolifération législatives qui résulte
du fait qu'on est dans une politique
aussi très imbriqué dans le droit de
l'union européenne et qui est ce qui
nécessite des ajustements très fréquent
de la loi française pour tenir compte
des évolutions européennes donc ça
rajoute un élément de complexité
supplémentaire mais une politique
passionnante et c'est une politique qui
n'est pas si désespérante que les
discours politiques où on peut pas pas
tellement politique polémique peuvent
peuvent laisser croire
l'une de vos fonctions aussi de vos
missions c'est d'être relations avec les
élus locaux
c'est ça c'est une fonction est ce que
vous avez l'impression que vous faut
quels que soient les partis ou les les
idéaux dehiba tout le monde tire dans le
même sens alors dont les gibiers on a
quand même une plutôt la ligne a
peut-être une couleur
dominante mais c'est pas bien dans les
avions dans les quartiers on n'a pas de
peu d'affrontements
disons politique de clivages politiques
très marquées quelques exceptions près
et puis vous savez sur la sur la
politique de la ville moi j'ai le
sentiment que tout le monde tire un peu
dans le même sens en vérité sur le fait
que ce dont on discute et en début de 2
de l'émission sur le fait qu'il faut
faire vivre le pacte républicain
sur le fait qu' il faut donner à ceux
qui ont le moins un peu plus pour qu'ils
puissent saisir leur chance je crois
qu'il ya une forme là-dessus d'union
républicaine
alors après il ya des personnes qui sont
d avis est différent en tout et tout
existe mais qui sont pas représentés
parmi les grands élus locaux des
yvelines avec lesquels je travaille que
vous travaillez vous êtes en fonction je
le disais depuis à peine un peu plus
d'un an dont on ne voit pas de tirer un
bilan de cette baisse qu est-ce qu il ya
des dans l'exercice de cette fonction
des choses qu'ils ont surprises
qui m'ont surprise demain je connaissais
un peu la politique de la ville avant de
venir
aider à les raisons
ce qui m'a alors il ya beaucoup de
choses qui m'ont surpris en positif en
fait donc je ne serai pas
je ne serais pas négatif sur ce qui m'a
surpris j'essaie de trouver des choses
qui m'ont surpris négativement en vérité
je ne trouve pas ce qui m'a surpris
positivement c'est qu'on a des
programmes en politique de la ville
j'avais toujours l'impression que la
politique de la ville c'était un peu du
saupoudrage de
d'actions diverses et variées mais qui
n'avait pas vraiment de de consistance
ou de capacité à modifier les choses là
on a quand même des programmes qu'il
s'agisse de la rénovation urbaine qu'ils
s'agissent de la politique éducative
avec la constitution des sites et
éducative bref on a un certain nombre de
programmes qui sont tout à fait robuste
et qui peuvent alors évidemment faut se
laisser un peu de temps mais qu'ils
peuvent à mon avis c'est pour ça que
j'étais optimiste tout à l'heure qui
peuvent changer la donne à mon sens de
manière déterminante dans les quartiers
régler fils éducatif parisot c'est un
programme qui est le seul humain
remarquable
on en avait parlé avec avec catherine
arnould a pour chanteloup les vignes on
a cinq maintenant sur le département des
yvelines on espère en avoir d'autres
mais prochaine vague et c'est vrai que
c'est un programme qui est tout à fait
intéressant parce qu'il met en relation
l'éducation nationale et l'ensemble de
l'environnement éducatif de l'enfant
pour lui donner toutes les chances de
réussir et faire en sorte même qu'il y
ait dans les quartiers en politique de
la ville des territoires d'excellence et
on a vu récemment à mantes-la-jolie un
collège innovant qui s'est ouvert qui
est aussi un
établissement d'excellence donc on va je
pense réussir à changer les choses dans
les quartiers dans ce qui m'a surpris
peut-être plus négativement
allez peut-être deux choses quand même
pour essayer
pour essayer de faire la balance et le
la vigueur du repli communautaire dans
certains quartiers mais pas surpris
parce que je m'y attendais mais c'est
quand même un sujet de préoccupation et
je crois qu'il faut que les pouvoirs
publics soient très vigilants on l'est
on quotidien mais il faut l'être
et oui mais ça va un petit peu un petit
peu de même le sentiment d'être
discriminées d'être différent dans les
quartiers la vigueur du sentiment d'être
discriminées dans le quartier en
politique de la ville qui parfois juste
un sentiment qui est parfois
malheureusement une réalité ça fait
partie des choses qui m'ont surpris ou
qui m'ont
interpellé merci infiniment si le préfet
voilà le vois que vous n'êtes pas une
sorte de sisyphe qui monte au rocher
dire ton nom il tient
on espère qu'ils tiennent un peu non et
l'état en général n'est pas un sisyphe
qui met un rocher qui retombe les
politiques publiques produisent des
effets mais c'est des effets de long
terme qui ne voient là qui sont vont
plus vite qu'une polémique sur ses news
merci beaucoup à faire merci beaucoup
[Musique]